my uh my buddy how about my buddy this
I've talked about this I talked this I
talked about this probably in like
episode five or something about how
people who spend time with you should
know who you are
almost drooled right there by the way
when I said who you are but dude I drew
by the way we ever talk in drool I do
that I've done that I don't remember
last time I've done it probably eight
months ago well I'm a 37 year old man so
it doesn't get so passionate that I
drool and guess what dude I don't that's
how it should be
dude if you don't drool a little bit
when you talk you if you don't drool
every now and then when you talk you
ain't [ __ ] that's it
that's it if you're checking your mouth
while you're talking you ain't [ __ ] lose
control baby lose control when you're
passionate you talking about some [ __ ]
you're talking about your job lose
control drool a little bit I do it guess
what guess what sometimes when I have
sometimes when I make love I drool if
your check in your own mouth when you
make love and you're thinking about oh
[ __ ] I can't I gotta [ __ ] keep my
mouth closed so I don't drool you are
not making love focus on nothing while
you're making love don't focus on the
girl
don't focus on you you focus on [ __ ]
nothing bro you focus on nothing or
you're not making love do you know where
you are when you make love elsewhere or
you're not making love all this [ __ ]
about Oh pay attention to your partner
pay attention to the can if you're not
focusing on elsewhere you never made
love be blissful be [ __ ] out to lunch
[ __ ] all
[ __ ] man if you're trying to please the
girl you ain't doing [ __ ] you ain't
doing [ __ ] when you're in it you're in
it right when you're playing baseball
you're not I gotta [ __ ] get all the
technical [ __ ] right I gotta this and
that you're loosey-goosey you're hitting
homeruns you're [ __ ] shagging fly
balls you're loosey-goosey man Willie
Mays dude caught the ball with his bare
hand he didn't try to it was there and
it was easier he did it he was
loosey-goosey and at that moment that
was the drool of baseball that was the
drool of baseball if you're talking and
you don't drool once every eight months
you ain't saying [ __ ] and if you make
love and you don't drool every other
time every third time you [ __ ] don't
make love you know what you're doing
you're [ __ ] at the partner that's
what you're doing you might as well go
at in and out and get a burger you're
not [ __ ] experienced in experiencing
the restaurant you're not experiencing
the [ __ ] when people say oh yeah
let's go to a steak house [ __ ] you dude
no it's not about going to a steak house
and getting a steak it's about feeling
where you're trying to and it's about
the moment dude that's why I'll make
plans that's what I'll [ __ ] make
plans
hey yeah [ __ ] Friday let's go to that
steak house Friday comes along I don't
want steak then what you got to go to a
steak house you're not making love to
the [ __ ] situation man go to the
place that makes you drool baby
I've [ __ ] I'm sure I lost a lot of
the people when I'm talking about this
but you guys who I lost I don't want you
in my cult anyway if the girl looks back
when you drool making love and she's
like what the [ __ ] Uber's outside if she
looks back at you if she likes it I got
a new [ __ ] roommate you ain't going
anywhere unless you want to but you
don't step it up dudes its 2018 coming
up drool more I'm serious too I'm I'm a
hundred percent serious you think drool
hasn't come out of my mouth while I was
onstage take a [ __ ] hike cuz that's
what I do that's oh I love that that's
my love you ever see [ __ ] Leonardo
DiCaprio act in Basketball Diaries snot
comes out of his [ __ ] nose yes a
little too much but at least he was in
it you got to get to that point we're
[ __ ] snots coming out of your nose
man well you ain't [ __ ] you ain't [ __ ]
any of these Wall Street [ __ ]
you think snots come out of there more
nose I'm business dude if I was on the
trading room floor and I was like sell
it buy it look at the stocks get it
going up down check the Dow you better
believe it that's my life's passion I
got snot I got drool I I got it I got it
and I'm making money dude I'm stacking
gouda and we're backing up the Brinks
truck while I'm a mess and I got a
[ __ ] I'm with stupid tie on cuz God
dress up and it's pointing to the guy
who's driest [ __ ] doing it for a job
this is my passion
let me stack the monster with the drooly
tie I'm stacking monster with a drooly
tie bro you [ __ ]
chassé Cudas piles are drooled in my
cult at the lobby
log cabin we don't go outside we got to
grow these plants let the drool hit the
ground let the plants [ __ ] blossom up
that's our garden this [ __ ] is real life
babies one of my dogs is in the corner
looking at me and one of my dogs is
literally putting his face up against
something like he's like I don't know
what's happening like he you know what
my dog looks like right now the end of
the Blair Witch Project when the guys
[ __ ] standing in the corner and you
know it's because the [ __ ] person
made him do that
or whatever the [ __ ] when I saw Blair
Witch Project bro I couldn't see for
[ __ ] a week I don't know what I was
talking about drooling before that let's
talk about something man I don't
remember I went off on a tangent this is
what happens though we are you know what
I hope I hope I hope you guys were
listening to that part of the podcast
with your parents cuz they need to know
cuz you know who's never droolin parents
right oh my they would go like that oh
my oh my